[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
emmanuel cho is the
former nfl linebacker co-host of fox
sports 1 speak
for yourself and has a new book called
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man
emmanuel good to have you on let me
start with that topic with lamar jackson
how is it that these defenses or a
defense knows what lamar jackson and the
ravens are doing when they get to the
line of scrimmage
uh as a middle linebacker in the nfl dan
i can tell you
it's not that complicated what do i mean
well last year lamar jackson took the
lead by storm so many of these nfl
coaches
hadn't seen the spread style run game
when i played at the university of texas
i was playing against a guy by the name
of robert griffin who won the heisman
his senior year my senior year
after you see it for a while you
understand okay if the back is offset to
the quarterback's right and he's about
two yards deeper than the quarterback
you're probably going to get an inside
zone type of run scheme
if he's offset to the quarterback's
right and he's even with the quarterback
you might get an option to the right
based on depth
perception of the running back based on
splits of the offense
you can pretty fairly anticipate what's
going on the problem dan is simple
last year you only had about three days
to prepare for lamar jackson if you were
going to see him that week
this year you've had about three four
months to prepare for lamar jackson all
off season
so i think they're starting to see the
adjustment catching up to the ravens
yeah but if lamar knows this the defense
knows this then
how how is it that the ravens aren't you
know counteracting this
um well because you can actually only do
so many things on offense particularly
if you live within a certain scheme see
when you're going to get up against a
guy like andy reid
he's doing ridiculous stuff tons of a
ton of different formations
a ton of different pre-snap shifts and
moves but when you're going against the
baltimore ravens
they don't do so much they just do it
excellently
and that's the difference when i was
playing against the carolina panthers in
13 14 and 15 with cam newton
preparing for them was grueling they had
thousands of formations hyperbole
obviously
but they could run so many different
things out of those formations the
ravens they keep it more simple
they just executed a higher level
there's a pro to that but also a con to
that as well
if i gave you their futures right now
lamar jackson or kyler murray
i would probably say
oh that's so tough let me say lamar
jackson
i know a lot of people are saying tyler
murray and i really like kyler murray
i probably though like um uh cliff
kingsbury and his offensive mind
more than i like um what they have going
on
in it with greg roman and with the
ravens remember this is a problem dan
when you talk about sports
so many look people look at just the
incubated team
oh well give me patrick mahomes over
deshaun watson
well sure but what if you would have had
patrick mahomes drafted
to bill o'brien's texans and deshaun
watson drafted
to uh andy reed's chiefs like it's just
it's never apples to apples when people
try to make these comparisons
and also when we start to handicap like
how long it takes for somebody to take
that next step and uh
you know it feels like receivers it
takes them a little while
to get the game doesn't come to them as
easy as some of the other positions
there
uh brandon marshall i remember telling
me it took him six years
to for the game to kind of come to him
quarterbacks it's coming to you right
away
dk metcalf it's sort of coming to him
right away that if i said
i'll give you any receiver for the next
five years
who are you taking and most people are
probably taking dk metcalf
how is it that he slipped by everybody
in the first round
uh well as a college football analyst
remember dk metcalf was often
often injured aj brown was also on that
team
receiver for the tennessee titans a.j
brown was probably a better collegiate
receiver than dk metcalf many would
argue particularly because of health
let's also not underestimate russell
wilson
tyler lockett was supposed to be a
gadget guy kylo lockett in the big 12
conference where i played college
football
he was a return ace return specialist he
had 200 yards receiving on 15 catches
just two weeks ago
let's not underestimate russell wilson
doug baldwin what was he an undrafted
free agent
turns into a perennial or a repeat pro
bowler
russell wilson's also playing a great
major factor
in dk's success and kudos to dk metcalf
for over achieving if you will when did
you start thinking about
this as a career when you were playing
dan i gravitate towards what i'm good at
in high school i went to an affluent
all-white
private school i was supposed to be a
national merit scholar my parents first
gen
my parents born in nigeria i'm first
generation american so dan
i'm thinking okay i'm gonna be a nerd go
to yale go to harvard
i wind up being six to 240 pounds i was
like well i guess we'll play football
um while playing football dan i was like
okay i kind of
understand i was never the fastest i was
never the strongest but i was typically
the smartest on the football field so i
said let me get into breaking down
games breaking down tape because it's
not what you know it's what you can get
the listener and the fan to know
and i realize i'm decently skilled at
that so that's why i moved into it
what did christian okoye mean to nigeria
christian okoye obviously the great
running back for the kansas city chiefs
everyone knows him as a nigerian
nightmare dan my first
email when i was a ninth grader in high
school
it was nigerian nightmare yahoo.com
my very first one so when you say what
does christian okoye mean to nigerian
americans to nigerian football players
he's the legacy and that legacy has
since been tried to be
since been carried on think about the
nfl draft game three
nigerian players were drafted in the
first round uh obviously jeff okuda i
remember him
uh i think noah igbo guinea another
cornerback from auburn and there was one
more player who's flipping my mind but
think about what christian okoye started
and how that legacy has continued to be
passed down
emmanuel ocho the former nfl linebacker
and he's the co-host marcellus wiley
with uh speak for yourself but the book
is uncomfortable conversations with a
black man
when did you think about doing the book
and why
yeah dan after the the racial tension
going on in our world
i said i have to do something to
alleviate some of this
i'm a sports analyst sure but before i'm
that dan i'm a black man
and before i was even that the world the
world saw me as a black man
i was a human being it's my job to leave
the world better than i found it i said
wait
i was immersed in white culture dan at
this all-white private school growing up
then i was immersed in black culture in
the nfl and in college
i realized there's a color and culture
issue dan like black people and white
people
we communicate differently and because
we communicate differently let me try to
act as a bridge
to allow my white brothers and sisters
to understand some questions
uh answer some questions that they may
never ask because they don't have black
friends to ask them to
or a black group or feel comfortable so
i said let me write this book
to help educate those that want to be a
part of the solution
in america what is the
i guess top question that we should ask
or you
that you want to answer oh such a great
question
um i think the top question which is
such a volatile
topic people talk about white privilege
well emmanuel i worked hard how can you
say i'm privileged dan let me say this
i currently have famous person privilege
i was walking down the street in beverly
hills dan i walk into a restaurant they
say
emmanuel i love your show your meal is
on me then the meal was free not because
i'm black not because i'm six two
because they knew who i was so many
people in america um
i submit that privilege just means you
have certain access to a space or
certain immunity from a space
um because of who you are so when you
talk about
white privilege it's understanding that
in america i have certain immunity or
certain access to certain spaces
it's not saying your life hasn't been
hard and saying your skin color hasn't
contributed
to the difficulty in your life i think
dan there's so many visceral reactions
based on
terms in our current society that really
turn people off but until we
open up our minds of understanding open
up our hearts to understand
we won't really see the unity that we
need and let me say this real quick
i played in the locker room for the
greater light and greater part of my
life
and people say well emmanuel in the
locker room people look past race
dan they look past religion because
we're all fighting towards a common goal
but in america the reason we have so
many divides
is because we're not all fighting
towards a common goal we don't all
realize
oppression exists racism may exist
systemic racism exists
so dan if you're not fighting towards a
common goal then you end up fighting
each other
and that is the difference between how
in a locker room you can overlook your
differences
but in the world we struggle to why is
it that in the moment
there is this uh blowback or this anger
or
resentment with those muhammad ali
martin luther king i even look at lebron
james and i shouldn't be just singling
out african americans
there are a lot of people who speak up
on on this topic
but it feels like it's after the fact we
look back
with reverence and admiration instead of
in the moment
you know i don't know how we're going to
look back on colin kaepernick
because in the moment and even now it's
still volatile
i don't know 15 20 30 40 years i don't
know how history treats him
ali they didn't treat him well uh martin
luther king
was divisive as well uh lebron james
you know today is divisive to a lot of
polarizing to a lot of people
why is it we don't see what's in front
of us or appreciate what's in front of
us
um there's twofold number one dan the
old quote you never know what you got
until
it's gone but now let me dive a little
bit deeper
no one likes to get uncomfortable in the
moment
this is a sports show so let's talk
sports university of texas i had a
strength coach called mad dog madden
he wore a huge gold chain around his
neck that said mad dog
he's probably about six four three
hundred plus pounds
dan do you think i like my strength
coach in college absolutely not
i didn't like when he was yelling at me
i didn't like when he was forcing me to
do something i didn't want to do
i didn't like when he was making me wake
up at 6 00 a.m to run gassers across the
football field in the hot texas heat
absolutely not but as i've gotten older
i've realized wait a second
everything he was doing for me at the
time was for my benefit
but more importantly everything mad dog
my strength coach was doing for me at
the time
was for the greater good of the team and
i think the issue at hand is
when you talk about guys like dr martin
luther king
lebron james uh muhammad ali the likes
what they're trying to do is for the
greater good
of the team the united states our team
which we're all on together
now you might not agree with some of
their philosophies you might not agree
with some of their terms i might not
have agreed
with all of these sets and repetitions
my strength coach was making me do
but the intention was pure behind it and
i think really dan we just
we don't like to get uncomfortable and
that's why i wrote the book
and that's why we're starting to see
some growth in our country
is there part of you that says is my
calling something above
just doing sports and breaking down uh
you know is carson wentz good enough to
be the starting quarterback for the
eagles
oh i so genuinely appreciate that
question definitely
dan i've realized there's a difference
between your career and your calling see
your career is what you're paid for
your calling is what you're made for and
while my career has been sports
x's and o's lebron james carson wentz
versus nick foles who was better
who is greater my calling has been
trying to bridge racial reconciliation
in this world my calling
has been trying to unite my black
brothers and sisters and my white
brothers and sisters
i realized dan this i didn't play in the
nfl to make a lot of money or to tackle
people
i didn't go to this affluent top college
preparatory school in
high school to get a phenomenal
education i think dan everything i've
gone through in my life
has led me to this moment has led me to
uncomfortable conversations with the
black man
has led me to the series which over 70
million people have now
seen in five months my calling dan is
bigger than myself
and i'm just glad to be a vessel to be
used in the moment
the most important question i'll ask you
and the most important question you'll
hear all day is
if it was you against marcellus wiley
and only one guy
one guy got out of the octagon uh who
would it be
uh well first off it would be me because
marcellus wiley would tire out
okay he doesn't work out anymore he's a
little soft around the edges if you know
what i mean
wow um and though he went to columbia
dan
i would outsmart him because i have two
degrees one being in sports psychology
so i would use all his tactics against
him don't let him fool you dan
he's got old guy strength though he's
coming up
he has grown man strength he got grown
man strength
good luck with the book and uh also with
the fox sports one with the
speak for yourself thank you and tell
marcellus we said hello thank you
emmanuel of course
thank you my brother all right emmanuel
ancho the former nfl linebacker
and uh the book is uncomfortable
conversations with a black man
uh this is a dialogue that he's hoped to
create that's honest straightforward
accessible to those who seek answers
a conversation that needs to happen to
men the racial divide in our world
the book uncomfortable conversations
with a black man